hey all this is lu temple you know me as
axle on the walking dead and you are
tuning in to flicks in the city
it's so lovely see here today Lou how
you enjoying the collector mania they
bought oh my gosh is so fantastic here
we are in Milton Keynes were at the Dons
football stadium there's a mass amount
of folks here from all parts of the
United Kingdom and they've been so kind
and so polite and and so well-versed I
have to say I'm so impressed with the
knowledge of the I call them the
audience as opposed to the fans because
I think they inform us as much about
what we do on our programs and films as
we do inform them so I'm so excited to
be here I love the UK and spend a lot of
time here my wife is from the UK
stratford-upon-avon so we come over
quite a bit and and it's always a
delight now you said you've been
informing you today about your character
acts on how well versed people are but
what have you enjoyed so much about
playing axel what I love about axle is
that he wears his heart on his sleeve so
in other words he says what most of us
are thinking and or wondering like you
know you must be a lesbian because you
got the short hair is if any woman that
wore short hair is a lesbian naturally
well that's not true but axl in his
honest genuine way makes it so or this
apocalyptic zombie situation is it's not
as bad as aids is it well of course it's
as bad as aids so I love that he says
the things that he feels and I think he
is it's very genuine but there's an
uncertainty about Axl he very well could
have been something that he wasn't
telling us yeah I mean if he always felt
that there was kind of more behind the
scenes they weren't quite sure which way
he might go I mean was that a deliberate
decision with you how you played him it
was absolutely i always wanted to give
the riders the opportunity to go that
way if we want to go down a dark path
I was reserving fangs if you will in the
closet and they could pull out but at
the end it was important for me to make
sure that axel was adored so that he
would be missed and it would be a gut
punch and I'm really proud with how we
pulled that off though I'm not happy not
to be on the show ID or being on the
show I'm so proud of the work that we
did and and and I thought acts a lot a
lot more to offer to the survival group
maybe maybe he would have kept Carol on
track but I'm sure that he would have
helped herschel in this scenario I think
that he might have been a brother figure
older brother for Daryl which he needs
again so a lot of things but at the time
that he left was that it served the show
and that's all that's important is
serving that the show how did you find
out and what was your kind of first
reaction when you found that axel was
getting the chop no not Axl uh a lot
like y'all but I found out three weeks
in advance I was the production the
producer called me and said you know
it's unfortunate but we gotta take axle
out and I sort of did what I call the
denial dance and offer a lot of other
options what about this alan guy he
seems to become a jerk and nobody has
attached to him we got to make it hurt a
little bit more near the guy and we
talked about taking off taking out a
couple of the regulars you know and so
after the cast became aware that I was
leaving they would come to me it was
sympathy and I and I would just
privately say dude you have no idea how
close it was being you and you wouldn't
be so sad but it was it was unpleasant
and I got rid of all of that
from my mindset really responded that I
have a job to do and it's to serve this
story and this is how I best serve the
story so I've got to make it a happy day
kind of sad so that you don't see it
coming and I'm like I say I'm really
delighted with how we pulled that up
that I remember the COS actually went to
bat for you didn't they and said we
don't want to lose him with étienne
Andrew Lincoln your um your lovely
countryman was so kind in standing up on
my behalf and going to the producers
saying this is probably not a valued
move as did others and there was quite a
debate so much so that they were when it
went down we actually did it they
weren't necessarily really prepared in
that they hadn't formed my life cast so
interestingly the producer of the show
Greg Nicotero who also directs a lot of
the episodes and is in charge of all the
special effect makeup he and I bear
certain resemblance in this area and
it's actually him as the dummy laying on
the ground and his life cast so I'm and
I'm honored for that because he's such a
an icon in the industry I mean did you
get one of the deaths dinners that they
do on the show I did and I and typically
the death dinners can be quite uh quite
sad and sorrowful I'm i purposely made
it very light and happy and and
embracing and but i've also been on the
other end the great thing about the
death dinner is that the check comes
around and it goes right by you unless
you're still on the show and then you
got to reach into your pocket and
they're quite quite pricey but in this
instance i really enjoyed my steak that
night for free yeah it always tastes
better but it's our free to most things
do most things do
now I know that on the day while I heard
on the day when you were shooting the
final scenes that you were trying not to
be too morose about it so you were
listening to certain music tracks tell
us about how how you did that you know
this is something that it happens quite
a bit on the walking dead Andrew Lincoln
is a big proponent in connecting with a
soundtrack for the day as is Norman
Reedus and and I had always done that
too particularly an unstoppable for Tony
Scott so on this particular day there
was a song that was right it's by a
musician citizen cope and it's a song
called bullets and a target which is
exactly what I was between that bullet
and Carol essentially from the governor
and its really upbeat and so that was
the that was the point of importance was
I wanted the day to be upbeat happy
rather peaceful telling a story that I'm
okay in this environment this is a good
place and oh wow that just happened and
I bet I didn't want to play the end of
the scene in the beginning and that's
always the trap you fall into so I
thought it worked great absolutely it
looks great on us on the screen and with
any seems that you shot as Axl that we
didn't actually get to see in the final
Sarah yeah there was absolutely there
was an incident when Rick comes back and
lets us know after having gone to rescue
some of the hostages from Woodbury where
we lose Oscar my friend the other
prisoner and my reaction in that was
anger and I ered and I held Rick Grimes
responsible for that and I got up in his
grill and we got physical about it we
shot this and it was great and Andrew
Lincoln was fantastic the problem was
he had to go from that seemed to a scene
where he's meeting new Tyrese and his
group and then spin right into seeing
the visions of Lori and it was just too
much heavy lifting continually so we had
to temper that down and that's okay
again we're just trying to serve the
story and that so I you know I was happy
I was happy with that what kind of
reaction if you had audiences to Axl
well everyone seems to adore Axl
everyone feels like his time was too
short and that he had more to offer and
people genuinely thought he was funny
there was a place that Axl brought a
certain amount of levity you know we
talked about saying the things that you
know everybody wants to say sort of a
breath of lightness and smile to axle
and so most people find a delight a
tickle with Axl and I I appreciate that
because that's what I was trying to land
yeah there we'll see what the partial to
his moustache shortly I must ask you a
question but I'll shave it for later yes
a funny story is that when I got hired
to do the walking dead i was actually
working on a film The Lone Ranger with
this young actor named Johnny Depp who
by the way keep your eye out he might
have a future so at that time as you can
see I had quite a mustache and I was not
going to be able to shave that so I told
The Walking Dead oh I I probably can't
do your show cuz you're not gonna want
the mustache and they said no no no it's
fine it's fine so we were able to
maintain it with that incredible stash
of mustache wax then I probably got from
her show they could use that mustache
wax for their their virus that they're
experiencing right now I might it might
serve them so yeah
maybe they've got a stash of it left
their of stash of the stash that's it it
is Movember right now so we're all
supportive of the male cause to grow
your facial hair out there you know in
Los Angeles right now where I live
interesting a mustaches I'm sure are
popular all over the world I'm in vogue
but lately ladies are putting on
mustaches a lovely lady such as yourself
and it's oddly very attractive I mean
they're not growing them that would not
be attractive but um they're wearing
kind of paste on and it's it's quite
cute god it's industry like every day
yeah you might see a very attractive
girl dress well with a mustache and it's
just something else to look at I suppose
intriguing i'll have to look out for
that i was wondering if Axl were you
know real person to be alive and you met
him how do you think you get on with him
I think I'd get on great with axel
because he likes to talk and I like to
talk we probably wouldn't hear each
other that's why I always say if I had
what would be my weapon of choice in a
zombie apocalypse it would be Michonne
except that she doesn't talk much and
that might be a fate worse than death
for both axial and Lou deny actually is
a great talker but an exceptional
listener danai gurira kira kira who
plays Michonne so um uh yeah I think Axl
would be a great but you know and he
would be fun to spin a yarn with as we
say in the south where did you get to
kind of know best on the show
oh such a great question um I got very
close with Andrew Lincoln because I felt
like I mean this guy he's there every
day in every scene and whether he's in
the scenery's not in the scene he's
there and his presence is felt and he
sets the bar and I just felt like I
wanted to support all that I cuz I've
been doing this long time and I'm pretty
aware and I see this guy putting this
type of effort forward and I'm like
buddy you deserve a a friend and he's
got everyone adores him I got close
people asked me what did you take away
from the walking dead I friends and
particularly Vincent Ward who plays
Oscar he's just a delightful friend and
Norman Reedus who's so cool but he's so
smart you nobody knows this but he is
Johnny Appleseed so in other words he
drops a lot of little seeds for the
writers to pick up on and develop his
character and that's why we love him and
I learned a lot from him as an actor and
and as a friend he's got such a cool
swag that is just fun to be around and
you know I I love melissa is so sweet
and just everyone everybody was great
and and of course Scott Wilson who I had
been just such a fan of his work well
beyond or before the walking dead you
know heat of the night in cold blood the
great gatsby my gosh and so he and I
would smoke cigars and I would listen
about what it was like to work with the
young Robert Redford or a Robert Blake
you know in the day or two be Burt
Lancaster's best friend you know these
were lovely things so such as such a
delight absolutely yeah
absolutely incredible I mean what an
experience have had experience and yet
we we go to work every day roll up our
sleeves the great thing about the
walking dead there's no hierarchy
there's no divas it's a lot of work we
got a short time to do a lot eight days
to shoot an episode and it's hot I mean
real heat in Atlanta Georgia and we're
outside with bugs and sun exposure and
ticks and snakes and it's very physical
and so it's more beat up at the end of
the day and everyone gives it their all
as if we might get canceled as if it's
the last week we try to do better every
week the show just goes and strength to
strength are we speaking of which I mean
if you could wave a wand and you could
have anything happen for future seasons
of the show what would you love to see
happen I would like I would like to see
I would like to see hope start to
materialize clearly hope is what is the
human condition we essentially are
hopeful and I would like to see a little
of that come to fruition I want to see
dreams start to be accomplished you take
a young boy like Carl you know as adults
on the walking dead we talked often
about we had had an understanding of the
world before all this as little boys
that played sports that had their first
kiss that went to school and proms and
yet this boy like Carl or a baby like
Judith what will their dreams be of a
memories memories so I want to start
start to understand what memories could
be as opposed to tear and desperation
and fear
and maybe because we live in a we live
in a world of survival right now we get
up and we wonder about our mortgage and
we wonder about the price of petrol and
loved ones being of succumbing to
disease and we healthcare and these and
politics and church and state and all
these big issues so I think that's why
the walking dead lands so much as it
does because it's it's real life it's
day-to-day survival none of us wake up
without survival on her mind one way or
another so I want to see our dreams
start to have delight in the show a
little bit I'd love to see that happen
olive see how that transpires as well
you always been very busy as you've had
a lot of stuff since walking dead as
well you got loads more stuff to come
just very quickly when it talked to you
a little bit about it you got wicked
flirts with abigail breslin sean bean
and james purefoy coming out tell us a
little bit about that Oh manual role in
it that's such as such a lovely film I'm
so excited for that to come out that
would be maybe breaking bad meets
winters bone so I'm really hopeful that
we land as an indie like winters bone
abigail breslin we know from Little Miss
Sunshine zombieland she's an amazing
young actress and she's in a situation
where she's trying to save someone she
cares for very much her uncle me who has
a bit of a extracurricular drug problem
he not only makes the local crystal meth
but he tastes a little bit of it too
he's a little bit of a user and she
tries to save him from her bad uncle
sean bean or seen being as i like to
call him he's a delight and she does it
under the come
confines of a chess match and so she
plays everyone against one another very
Machiavellian of a sixteen-year-old girl
and James Purefoy is a infiltrated DEA
agent right in the middle of it another
countrymen he's amazing and so is Sean
so I'm really excited for this movie and
it's directed by mark young and look for
that it's really it's really going to be
great yeah that's incredible I can't
wait to see it also got houses have
bitten secrets and zombie X as welcome
yes there's a little bit about you today
House of forbidden secrets is it's quite
delightful because it is a ghost story
and it's very psychological and it is
it's a little bit of calling on a
witches coven that returns and the great
thing about it is that I get to be an
ungodly Catholic Irish priest it's such
a fright that they've had these troubles
but you come in and have a spot of tea
but truly his father Elias you called
this on upon yourself hadn't you so that
was a lot of fun for me um with my Irish
Spring Irish accent uh zomb X is a
zombie conspiracy theory the bad weather
hurricane in New Orleans occurred and
the government deposited some
pharmaceuticals as a test market in New
Orleans that went rogue and caused
people to become flesh eating zombies
maybe not unlike this bath salt
situation and as a libertarian disc
jockey I kind of
blow the whistle and we go on the road
to search for the the antidote it's with
Malcolm McDowell Sid Haig John Doe and
Tom Mariah and David Christopher and
it's it's really great it's a lot of fun
and I had a great time being this
character Aldous Huxtable whose large
and bigger than life an aura tater and a
preacher and yet he's got to take the
rubber to the road and remove the mic
and go out and actually be proactive and
do something which is scary for him so
it's great that's a variety there
looking forward to seeing all of those
thanks so much for talking to us delight
and keep keep tuning in to flicks in the
city and because axel tells you so you
you follow me
you